die lage und portugal ist dramatisch die
sieben tagen stil denn es liegt bei über
700 weltweiter rekord
das land ist im total locker und das
gesundheitssystem am boden jetzt kommt
auch noch dass mediziner müssen eine
auslese betreiben wem geholfen wird und
wem nicht es gibt zu wenig ressourcen
und zu viele kranke dafür steht am
eingang von portugals größten
krankenhaus in lissabon ein gelbes zelt
kommt ein krankenwagen an hält er zuerst
hier ärzte überprüfen den zustand der
patienten werden keine
lebensbedrohlichen zustand ist wird
gleich abgewiesen mehr als 350 corona
fälle werden aktuell in der klinik
behandelt wir machen nicht diese art von
triage wir erhöhen stattdessen unsere
kapazitäten aber wir befinden uns
bereits fast am maxi lage auf den
intensivstationen ist brenzlig ein ganz
portugal waren am vergangenen freitag
nur noch sieben intensivbetten für
corona patienten frei besonders tragisch
verstorbene patienten werden in solchen
kühlcontainern aufbewahrt weil die
kühllager in den krankenhäusern
überfüllt sind
die krise in portugal hat die regierung
und veranlasst sich hilfesuchend an
deutschland zu wenden mit erfolg an
diesem mittwochnachmittag sind zwei
flugzeuge der bundeswehr lissabon
gelandet an bord 26 ärzte und pfleger
beatmungs und intensiv geräte und 150
krankenbetten 26 soldaten unsere dafür
einen sind heute am flughafen lissabon
angekommen und wurden auch direkt von
der portugiesischen
gesundheitsministerin dankend in empfang
genommen und wir stehen jetzt hier
direkt vor einem der krankenhäuser dem
krankenhaus hospital da luz wo die
bundeswehrsoldaten ab morgen zum einsatz
kommen sollen
die bringen halt eben die angesprochenen
150 betten mit aber auch 50
beatmungsgeräte und infusionen
infusionsgeräte und dadurch sollen sie
eben hier helfen einmal mit dem material
aber auch vor allen dingen mit der
personal kraft denn eines der
gravierenden probleme was uns auch im
krankenhaus gestern begegnet ist ist der
personalmangel im gesundheitswesen hier
in lissabon und ganz portugal denn die
personal kräfte im gesundheitswesen sind
in der finanzkrise 2011 bis 2014
ausgewandert haben sich woanders job und
werden ihm jetzt sehr sehr dringend
gebraucht peter du warst gestern den
ganzen tag da auf einer intensivstation
in lissabon
und wir haben gerade auch die bilder von
den kühlcontainern gesehen die ein ja
doch erschreckend worauf stellt sich
lissabon noch ein wie groß vermutet man
wird dieses sterben dort noch ja diese
bilder mit dem kühlcontainer wo wir eben
heute waren das waren wirklich sehr sehr
erschreckende bilder wir waren da 15
minuten gerade da und in diesen 15
minuten sind drei leichenwagen
vorgefahren um eben särge aus diesen
vollen kühlcontainern herauszuholen die
kommen da eben einfach gar nicht mehr
hinterher
die tote toten abzuholen und dann eben
zu bestatten es dauert auch in
krematorien sehr viel länger bis leichen
dann wirklich personen dann wirklich
bestattet werden können und heute wurden
240 tote in ganz portugal gemeldet das
sind zwar sinkende zahlen aber auch der
intensivmediziner mit dem wir gestern da
in diesem krankenhaus gesprochen hat der
hat uns gesagt die starken portugiesen
und portugal stellen sich auf jeden fall
noch auf schwierige zwei wochen ein
denn dass das der höchste punkt der
infektion der wurde am freitag erreicht
seitdem sinken die infektionszahlen aber
wir kennen das aus deutschland die
todeszahlen die steigen dann erst noch
in den zwei wochen danach
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren